foreign
Caleb's in Austin Texas hey Caleb how
are you
I'm doing well Dave how are you better
than we deserve how can we help
um I was calling because
um I'm getting ready to get married and
I have myself and my fiance we have
about 200 000 and that are close to it
uh that we are trying to figure out
what's the best Avenue for us to kind of
take good Lord who's the doctor or
lawyer
no
uh neither of us actually
um I uh I went to a private school to
get my bachelor's degree and what and in
Business Administration
okay
and so she got a degree in what
Communications
and the two of it's just all student
loan debt or what
it's not all student loan debt uh about
I want to say
probably about 80 of it is student loan
what's the rest
uh the rest is a a car loan that I have
how much is that and
it's a I I think I was still uh 47 on it
and you just graduated from college
in 2020 yes okay so what is your income
uh my income uh this last year I grossed
117. okay what about her
42 uh after taxes I believe do you see
where the problem is Caleb
I think so uh but that's why I was
calling well I'm gonna give you a hint
since you're still thinking it's the
cars
these cars are so expensive yes you've
got 80 000 in student loans but the cars
you you could really set yourselves free
if you made some decisions with these
cars all right you have one that's 47
what's the other one
the other one is
her car
30 30. okay you're right then good
you're right it's both of them
now give yourself a wedding present and
sell both these pieces of crap that have
rang trying to drive you into the bottom
of the ocean man good Lord when are you
supposed to get married
uh November of 2024. yeah
you're going you're going to drive away
from the church in a hoopty my man
if you're smart
is anybody paying for this what like is
is your family contributing to this
wedding or are you guys paying for it in
cash what's the plan
we are paying for it in cash okay um
and I've been saving for that right now
I'm still missing 50 Grand what's the
other 50 Grand
uh
I'm not I'm not sure it's more so it's
more like 180 between us I believe like
what yeah so it's like 180. I think I
got one I got 150 though
is it from her side I'm sorry yeah the
restaurant the restaurant credit cards
from her side I believe okay yeah okay
so here's the thing and I think that you
know this but in case you don't I want
to make it clear until you get married
you guys are working on this separately
so I it's good that you've talked about
it it's good that you both know what's
going on right both of you looking over
each other's plan because it's getting
ready to be our plan come November but
yeah so here's what we're gonna do I
want you two to go through Financial
Peace University as our wedding gift to
you and we're going to pay for it okay
if I give it to you will you use it as
part of your pre-marriage counseling
I I don't see any reason why not
absolutely okay this is a non-week class
nine lesson class you get in a small
group that's going to guide you step by
step by step on where how to go from
where you are now which is a a hot mess
okay into uh you know really taking this
actually a good income you know you got
a hundred and hundred and fifty hundred
sixty thousand dollar household income
once you're married you should be
millionaires
within just about seven or eight years
if you'll follow what we're going to
teach you but if you go do your stupid
butt stuff that your friends are all
doing you're gonna keep these cars
because you're afraid of what somebody
thinks or because you like the car and
you like the car more than being wealthy
someday that's what you're that's the
trade you're making so both of these
cars are insanity
they were Insanity when you bought them
and you need to get rid of them and get
cheap inexpensive cars and then lay into
the student loan debt and uh if you do
that
you know you guys could clear this 18
months after marriage you could be debt
free and if you're if you're debt free
if you don't have a payment in the world
and you're in your 20s making 160. you
can become millionaires then okay you
really can and you can drive whatever
you want later but you went and bought a
bunch of crap you couldn't afford an
expensive education that you overpaid
for
and a cars that you couldn't afford and
so you've been just buying anything you
wanted because some idiot would loan you
the money
and it got you into a mess and uh so if
I were you guys if if you were my I'm
old you don't you know you're younger
than my kids so uh but if I were you if
you were my kids I would sit down and I
would love you so much that I would be
very clear with you like I am right now
because we love you and we want you to
win and uh so
and be smart about that wedding yeah
don't let that keep the wedding down you
know there's no correlation between the
expense of the wedding and the success
of the marriage no piece of research
between that no piece of research
between the size of the ring and the
last thing of the marriage except
possibly an inverse relationship but the
uh um oh my gosh so yeah you guys have
got some real serious
changes in the way you view the world in
order to a clean up this hot mess and B
become wealthy but I can we can show you
how to do it and I will do that as our
gift to you because we care about you
and we want you to win but dude you got
to change some stuff this is not gonna
if you just keep doing what you're doing
it's going to get bad it's not it's
you're going to have a really tough
young marriage it's gonna be very harsh
I hope she's on board for this WOW uh he
called the crazy people on the radio he
asked for it there you go man that's
good hey hang on I'll send a pick up and
we'll get you guys signed up so Jade I
was on uh Neil Cavuto on Fox yesterday
Neil and I've been friends for 25 years
or so and uh of course he always pokes
at me makes fun I mean I make fun of him
he's cheap and um he's not here to
defend himself but he is cheap and
um but he uh he was like playing this
clip that went viral we had like 37
million impressions of this clip and it
was me doing what we just did just now
yes
and he's like you're so tough and I'm
like dude that is not tough I didn't
raise my voice I wasn't yelling at
anybody nobody got cussed at I mean how
is that tough where did you come from
that that's tough you I said Neil you're
pretty easily triggered what are you a
snowflake with the uh you know I mean
really that's not tough that's me
telling you the truth because I love you
yeah but Dave people think that's tough
because people think that they should be
able to well everybody just goes along
with people's stupid stuff yeah and if
you love somebody and you go along with
their stupid stuff that's not an act of
love no that's a that's an act of
cowardice enabling yeah it's enabling
and so if you want to be enabled guys
don't call this show because we're not
going to enable you we love you we're
going to tell you like it is we're going
we're gonna we're gonna listen we've all
we've all done stupid stuff she had a
half million dollars in debt I went
bankrupt in my 20s I mean we've all done
stupid stuff here nobody's exempt from
it but but we're not gonna stay in it no
that's the thing and we're gonna move in
a Direction that's positive for for you
we want you to win but they do need to
go watch that clip though if they
haven't seen it it's not that come on
it's what we do every day here on the
show I don't understand why it went
viral it's a great clip go watch it